a major blow tonight to president
biden's immigration policy a judge
ruling the administration must reinstate
a trump error mandate that biden
scrapped earlier this year this as fox
news gets an exclusive look at how one
police department is dealing with the
record migrant surge at the border chief
correspondent jonathan hunt has the
story tonight again from la jolla
this is barely starting
it's
6 30 the weather's already beginning to
cool down so we're going to start seeing
a lot of activity right now it's not
just the u.s border patrol that is
stretch thin local law enforcement on
the southern border is under pressure
too officers like sergeant ismail gaza
with the la jolla police department out
every night in the tough terrain next to
the rio grande backing up border agents
and lending a helping hand to migrants
who are frequently disoriented
dehydrated and desperate i'm a parent
myself
and sometimes when i see these kids and
it's heartbreaking
that their parents put them through this
sergeant gaza says he didn't train for
this but he and his fellow officers had
no choice but to step up when the number
of migrants crossing the border exploded
this year when we see the two 300 mark
like wow something we weren't used to
we're just used to running
the expressway
and patrolling our city streets
and now with this
let me tell you it's overwhelming many
of these migrants claiming asylum may
now be dealt with as they were under the
trump administration returned to mexico
and told to wait there until their
asylum case is adjudicated the so-called
remain in mexico policy that the biden
administration scrapped earlier this
year the fifth circuit court of appeals
on thursday upheld an earlier court
decision ordering president biden to
reinstate the policy as early as today
it's the latest in a series of legal
setbacks for the biden administration
with many of the courts now hearing
these cases presided over by judges
appointed by president trump
brett
jonathan hunt along the border jonathan
thank you